all right welcome back to Hannity we are
live from the spin room we are at the
Reagan Library in beautiful SEI Valley
California and well the governor this
great state Gavin Newsome is with us how
are you Governor good to be back with
you Sean all right now that you went on
your little media tour with all your
liberal siant you come back to reality
and you love doing my show better you
just told me off air I love doing your
show the most I mean it's unbelievable
that you can publicly say something
that's amazing by the way favored nation
status for me the Reagan Library at
Republican debate where else would I
want to be wow this is it this is home
court home court so now I'm going to ask
you so honest question so you see the
atmosphere you feel the electricity you
feel the room oh I know where you're
going you know where I'm going I know
where you're going okay and you we just
finished a presidential debate here you
are promoting a presidential candidate
Governor want know cuz I know the truth
in your heart in your mind you want this
but you have basically gone on a med
Ator sucking up to Joe Biden and you
know he's a cognitive mess you know it I
also know he's got an extraordinary
record to run on and I could be more
proud by the way record on the border
objectively he was a winner tonight no
doubt yeah no no that's not that's not
spin these guys identified problems and
Biden actually has not only identified
Solutions he's gotten bipartisan deals
to begin the process of implementing
those look into that camera right there
and you tell the people watching yeah do
you think this border is secure cuz they
keep telling us it's closed and secure
do you believe the southern border is
secure do you believe with all the
fentanyl deaths and opioid death is this
border secure I believe Ronald Reagan
was right in 1986 when he supported
comprehensive immigration well he also
said it was the worst decision he ever
made yeah but I believe that he did the
right thing for the right reasons
because he recognized it's not just a
border issue that the entire systemis
the entire system needs to be reformed
we haven't reformed since ' 86 not the
ASL system I believe in Jo successful I
think Joe Biden has been an unbelievably
successful secure the Border we we all
agree we have border challenge we all
agree we need to we need to reform the
Asylum system we agree in strong borders
not successful in securing the Border I
think the Republican party is complicit
in this as well you cannot do things I
mean it's just factual B wasure under
Donald Trump that's wildly overstated
but I get your fundamental Point clearly
the challenges are more acute today and
by the way I don't need to be educated
on this I have the largest landport in
the Western Hemisphere here in the state
of California I don't disag State and
and and it's Theon world we had 7.8% GDP
growth in in in in 2021 what's and we
dominate on Innovation and entreprene
pays for housing food clothing education
healthc care who pays for that well we
had 177 .7 billion operating Surplus
over two fiscal years and I just did an
$18.5 billion tax rebate the largest in
American history as we expanded
universal healthcare and we're providing
more services including by the way
health insurance which Ronda santis
apparently wasn't even aware of the
question you save that for the debate
with Ron here's the next thing so I come
into your state yes sir first thing I
love to do what is is bring money to
your economy I appreciate I go straight
to In-N-Out burer that is one of the
greatest things your state legit
including the weather including the the
the terrain is phenomenal you can keep
going but yes it's all phenomenal
however then I'm passing gas station
after gas station and gas station oh
yeah oh you're right excuse me gouging
us oil companies are screwing us $4 a
gallon in every other state yeah $7 I
saw here seven why is your state near as
of today I I monitor this very close I
just did a special session we became the
first state in the country to do price
gouging legisl ation with a new monitor
just went into effect these oil
companies are ripping us off $2 only
ripping off California $26 this mystery
sech charge that they've been advancing
for years and years but the average
around the country SC and I
anywhere $650 and7 $26 higher you're
absolutely right no your state is much
more than every other state exactly $2
higher because they're screwing us
there's no justification it's not
regulation taxs 85 cents 85 cents low
carbon fuel standard 85 much California
get per gallon for gasoline tax when you
add the gas tax you add cap and trade
and you add the lowc carbon fuel
standards and then periodically add and
I'm P I'm mean as transparent I can be
and you add our unique blend you get a
differential around 85 cents that you
can justify not
$26 that's where the oil companies
should dollar more you want to trust the
oil companies I can assure you these
guys don't have your back or the
American let me tell you something when
Donald Trump was President gasoline
prices Nationwide never averaged $3 a
gallon never once averag we have pulling
back another million barrels we didn't
have OPEC plus screwing us we didn't
have a war in Ukraine we didn't have we
weren't going through no we weren't also
going through this coid supply chain
reality so there was a lot of competing
factors that led to some of this by the
way but he also adoped he made us he
made the country energy dependent by
way we are more energy dependent today
look that up it's a fact and if you no
no no it's just factually and true Jo
Biden unilaterally disarm I encourage
the people watching look
at94 quads Google 9.5 all the rest has
put Morey independent today under Biden
Pence doesn't know that your audience
doesn't know that more domestic oil
production than any time in history
we're on Pace this year that's a fact
you guys keep keep making that up no we
don't make it up we were energy
independent and now we're not we are
energy independent no we're not energy
exporters are not Sean this is going to
be so much fun when this gets P back
tomorrow anir go there look at all the
other rest4 quads that's the margin it's
the highest margin of net energy export
in America's history under the Biden
Administration I did have a little fun
and for once you actually got back way I
can't wait for PolitiFact tomorrow there
going to be some fun PolitiFact why
don't you
go to the Washington Post fact Checker
needs Pinocchio then coming your way you
get four pinocchios your way all right
so I come into your state yes I love
In-N-Out Burger high price of gasoline
of course not your fault uh although you
admit 85 cents of it is here's the other
thing so I have a guy driving me loves
California hates your taxes okay and
this is what we see he points out to me
a bridge being built yes sir for the
people at home imagine this they're
building the bridge for mountain lions
it cost $100 million some of it private
money some of it government money a lot
of private money some of it government
money so you're Building Bridges from
mountain lions and
rattlesnakes among other it's a wildlife
Crossing wild we've seen so many
accidents we want to protect people's
health and safety impacting the economy
and insurance and traffic in the region
because of wildlife Crossings and we
want to address a vision for this state
as it relates to setting aside 30% of
our land to be protected for future
Generations vast majority of that comes
from the Wallenberg Foundation private
sector and it's inspired a generation of
kids and we want to inspire other
like-minded Wildlife polies across the
country so you got this debate with
Governor Ronda s excited about it um
more so tonight he lied about fracking
Nikki Haley laid him out he lied about
fracking he lied to the American people
tonight he did an executive order by the
way there's only going to be two of you
and and but Sean you guys you don't like
him I know no I just don't like well I
don't like people that demonize other
people or or or uh or go after
vulnerable communities but also don't
like liars he Nikki Haley laid him out
tonight he signed a 2019 executive order
I'm a governor I know what an executive
order is why would you sign an executive
order saying you will not do offshore
oil rigs in your backyard then blame
Biden for not doing more across the
country Havey is remarkable and Haley
save that for the debate here's here's
my exit question happened tonight under
any circumstances at all yes yes or no
will you ever ever accept the Democratic
nomination to run for president in 2024
on under any circumstances at all that's
a yes or no I I I'm looking forward I
was just in Chicago with the DN I don't
need the long answer I want the yes or
no answer President Biden's inauguration
will you accept it under any circum not
just it's it's a
hypothetical no no under any ccum it's
ridiculous Joe Biden's our presid call
me ridiculous Joe
B in out Joe bidden won the debate
tonight and you're right about in and
outb and that's a great way to end you
are right about in about all right but
the last thing is all those stupid
interviews you did made you prefer to do
my show well I mean I I love talking
about gas prices and Wildlife crossing
that's all the time we have left thank
you Governor uh hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else